this is much worse this is a lot work
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the power drill massacre
now I know that sounds like fun times
and sunshine and rainbows everywhere but
I've been assured that this game is
plenty terrifying hello whistling wind
I'm sure you heart can only good will
for me to do that was that my bad is
that the game over everyone had a car
crash oh well oh no oh Jeff are you okay
uh I can't feel my legs
don't worry Jeff I'll go get help by
myself in these woods all is gonna be
good now there are two options to this
game there was oh this is the worst
headache ever I think it my dad's
something to do with the car crash that
just happened now there were two options
to this mode there was DVD mode and VHS
mode but I tried both and it seemed like
VHS mode added this layer of stuff
because the game's low-poly by himself
but I think I'm alright it's getting
dark better get the flashlight out of
the trunk okay if you say so
whoa hey yeah because the DVD mode it
was almost too clean oh wow that is
weird controls okay how do I my
flashlight pick it up I would've seen
that was the weirdest flashlight pick up
sound I've ever heard in my life now how
do I use it
f oh my god it is F where's Jeff Jeff Oh
Jeff Jeff don't look so good I'll come
back for you Jeff my heart will go on
okay so what am I supposed to do Wow
alright so anyway I think this game is
supposed to be reminiscent of like the
old 90s style of
movies that happened like the alone in
the woods the the Freddy's of the world
was that was that a thing
what does that what was that a thing I
needed to worry about
okay don't just cut out the music like
that especially when you bring it in so
suddenly
hello does anybody live here that's
maniacal and murderous please what a
creepy old shed it's boarded up but the
top isn't maybe I could bash it down
with my strong arms oh is that a Penta
oh that's a pentagram Oh God
lovely looks like some kids drew a
pentagram back here yeah just like
Freddie was a kid or Jason just like
Jason was a kid okay I'm rushing
headlong into my doom I wonder what's
gonna await me on the other side of this
hellhole okay it seems like a precarious
path to be sprinting up at full speed
good thing I got this all this training
as a climber how's it going alright then
I'm guessing that might have been the
sound of a checkpoint and maybe I saved
right before I died
okay by the way these controls are so
janky by the way because it's keyboard
turning but the mouse is like super
sensitive okay
wait that was that was there was someone
up here sassy show AHA this door is open
no it's closed watch it go inside oh
sure
alright what a creepy building no no no
okay I'm not gonna talk about that one I
can talk about the pentagram but no you
no likey you know lucky hard it's going
to be to run over
I'm sorry is someone in the toilet there
that doesn't want to be bothered
no it's just a haunted but ghosts ain't
gonna be test by nobody I don't think I
should be wandering into these toilets
because I know from my eternal horror
game instinct that toilets are bad and
yet here I go Oh ignore my own advice is
anybody here oh hey what is that who is
it a key looks like oh it's a key good
can I get out of here pick it up oh why
not got a key with red paints stop it
stop that that's really weird the sound
effect choices that you make alright
that's okay I'm too experienced in all
the horror games I played to be swayed
by any sudden silly scares only the big
bad ones are gonna get me it seems like
a lot of places I could run into and
beat corner didn't die whoa what does
that say sugar tunnel right okay is this
like a taking candy from a person in a
van situation where I'm supposed to go
into some sugar tunnel and then get to
candy there's a candy man coming for me
oh that's how we're gonna be oh that's
how we're gonna play this [ __ ]
Oh this is how this game is gonna be
well screw you where am i I don't think
I'm in the same place I was Oh Hobie
wait no I am hang on oh no I'm not those
stairs weren't there before
oh damn it oh damn it oh damn it
do I still have my key who's there
someone there that I shouldn't like
there's somebody there it's locked
metal door I feel like I'm being watched
here let's feel like I'm being drilled
in the spine I'm trying to find my way
back just in case I didn't I like drop
the key or something but I need to go
get it all right I don't want to play
mr. Candyman I don't wanna play I think
is it yes okay got it
wait no this is different looks like an
article ripped out of a new favorite
sure let me take all the free time in
the world read this the search continued
for two missing campers in the Pocono
Mountains Masons he's Hardin and Lori
summers of Long Island New York I've
been missing since June 8th our campsite
and belongings have been located by the
investigators a few leads police say
there are no visible signs of struggle
and this continues to be a rescue
mission the wrist is missing it is dated
August in 1982 five years ago okay good
I thought was gonna be some
self-referential ball an old desk look
like okay so I think I might have picked
it up because it was on the other desk
counter Wampus to where I was so what
exactly am I looking for by the by oh
hey it's a cute face what does that mean
this to the sugar tunnel that's what you
said before but it ended up in me dying
I don't think I'd like to sugar tunnel
the sugar town Elena's sweetest I
thought it was gonna be
sugar tunnel sugar baby please don't
stab me in the body
oh sure I'm glad everyone didn't get to
see what happened there that would have
been a thing have you even seen the
monster yeah all right let's try again I
guess oh now I'm starting the beginning
I wasn't star I saw that I think
everybody else saw it too
okay I already already read this I
already read read that okay what okay I
gotta keep I think that's the key with
the bloodstains because for some reason
this place is kind of randomly generated
okay so I think I think that's the key
that I need to get out maybe or maybe go
down the sugar tunnel which keeps
leading to my death so as soon as I get
to the sugar tunnel I'm going to book
he's like it's 1982 okay all right here
we go here we go here we go I don't get
caught on nothing here we go oh oh oh oh
oh yes yes yes yes yes yes Jenny got oh
sorry thought Oh check it out
Bobby is this Matt oh that's bad
mikono vanishings no trace of missing
campers 1985 since 1978 12 campuses
disappeared over a 100 mile stretch of
the Pocono Mountains we conduct dozens
of rescue missions each year says Park
Ranger people come up here to camp and
hike all the time without any experience
accidents happen while most refuse are
successful these twelve has stumped Park
Rangers and local police campfires
without burning boots and Jack's left
behind radio still playing it's like
these people were ripped away from the
campsites says a Bradley who was
involved in the search for I can't read
anymore the ink is faded okay
or maybe the story was too horrible and
too relatable so the key yeah okay I got
a key with green paint splatter okay so
do I need to find a green door
Green Green Green Green Green the door
oh no oh no no it's a green blue and red
I need I need three keys to be able to
get out of here what a bunch of baloney
I'll go downstairs sure yeah that'll be
fun oh good it's open okay this is much
worse this is a lot work I'm gonna try
to go downstairs again well you all know
how well that turned out for me last
time I don't wanna I know what can
happen
oh that's so much better
I'm gonna try this this way Oh didn't
happen that time oh all right okay
mmm looks like a key yeah sure oh good
the green paint key cuz I haven't
already got that one before why bleep
whip whip whip things seem to be going a
lot better this time I haven't been
murdered yet so that's a plus I think I
can get out of here now probably sure
wish I could see what's in front of me
that that would be a delight unlike any
other what huh
what happened what'd I do so apparently
I broke the game for some reason sooner
I found a bug and I had to start over
again be right back when I get to where
I was okay so I'm back inside sorry for
all the problems apparently VHS code had
a bug where it would loop over the
effects so now I'm on DVD mode so it's a
little clearer but you guys can see what
I meant by it remove some of the
immersion there so we're back into it I
don't know why I'm so happy about it but
we're back into it okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay I'm a little bloody now
I'm a little bloody now I'm a little
bloody but I'm okay okay gave so hard I
don't know where he is I don't know when
to run away I don't know where to run
over the whispering voices are always a
good touch I think personally I've
regret regret regret regret regret
regret he is Maximus
I am the prophet of regret I'm gonna try
to go down the sugar tunnel again oh
this is a bad idea this is one of them
bad ideas I have a lot of good ideas
okay
Becky's never gonna spawn there again
never gonna spawn there again holy [ __ ]
I gotta fix Cameron just cuz I panic and
I swing the mouse in a rapid circle
which everyone knows when you're about
to die that's exactly what you should do
okay oh I get it okay these are his
tunnels
these are his tunnels that's how he pops
around the house so much okay that makes
more sense okay so that must be what the
sugar tunnel is the tunnel for his sweet
tooth no no no no no no
oh geez ons good god it's not fun I
gotta call it quits now because my voice
can't take it the number of involuntary
screams is actually thrashing my voice I
hope is like the most terrifying
experiences all the sudden out of
nowhere there's no better term for a
jump scare than that but it wasn't
random oh man oh man I've been playing
it for about an hour now and my voice is
like really really thrashed if I keep
going I'm gonna damage it so I gotta
stop now I think I was getting close but
I think that might have been it and I
just I wasn't going quick enough cuz he
was on my tail or something I don't know
what it was either way if you want to
see me finish this let me know in the
comments below or if I was already close
to the end it's not much reward who
knows play this for yourself by checking
the link on I've got to get my voice of
rest but thank you for the suggestion
and also let me know what other scare
games you want me to play in the
comments down below thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see
in the next week